hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the Capablanca
saga which means we were back at the
1918 tournament of New York where a capo
Blanca will for the second time faced
his old rival Frank James Marshall in
the first round of the tournament he
already defeated him it was the famous
famous game that we already shown if you
haven't seen it really a brilliant game
the one where Marshall employs the
Marshall attack for the first time if
you haven't you check it out it will be
the first link in the description below
if you have then just enjoy the rest of
the or the rest of the tournament
kupo Blancas still undefeated in this
tournament this is already round eight
so he already played against everyone
now he's gonna play against everyone
once again as it is a double round-robin
and all victory so far for a couple
months
only one draw in round three against Roy
tor Turnbull black and it's just just
you know a nice a nice clean tournament
for a couple Blanca so without further
ado let's check it out and this is
really an amazing game I do hope you
like the title as well and as you can
see we've already used this quote
several times in order to improve your
game you must study the endgame before
everything else so you know whenever I
walk down the street or you know I'm
enjoying a nice beer or something and
someone asks me how to improve his chest
I just tell them you know study the
endgame that's what Capablanca said
that's what I think is the correct way
to do if you want to improve your game
but without further ado let's check it
out Marshall has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 we have d5 Knight to f3
Knight to f6
we have c4 and of course you all know
what we're going into we have East 6 the
Queens gambit declined
Knight to c3 with Knight B to d7 Bishop
to g5 by Marshall Bishop to e7 III with
castles and rook to c1 this is the most
standard aligner of the Queens gambit
the client possible with c6 and Queen to
c2 and the theory didn't really move
from this health since this was played
and a hundred years from since this was
played to give a comparison in 2016
Wojtek played this exact same position
against Charlotte or mom in Europe and
the game ended in a draw so you can see
that even the players of those days
really had
firm grasp of everything the principles
the the openings the D everything
d captures on c4 with Bishop captures on
c4 NR Capablanca goes for this maneuver
which just allows him to trade a few
pieces and then make blacks position a
little bit easier and hopefully transfer
the game into a name game with Bishop
capture 77 Queen captures on e7 and here
marshal castles instead of castling you
can also go Knight e4 or knife to e2 if
you're not interested in allowing black
trade yet another piece but Marshall
doesn't care if you just castles we have
Knight captures on c3 by capablanca not
be captures although it is a more
principled move we have Queen captures
on c3 by Marshall and now just b6
preparing to fianchetto the lights for a
bishop
we have E for by marshal preparing e5
and now comes the bishop the b7 and now
just rook F to e 1 we have rook F to d8
by kappa blanka and now just d5 as long
as Queen still remains on the e7 square
it does make sense to put d5 so nice the
c5 of course you're not interested in
capturing we have D captures on e6
Knight captures on e6 and here a very
interesting moment in the game Marshall
can play Queen e5 you can just keep the
tension you know try and improve the
position of his pieces but he actually
decides to give up his life square
bishop for a knight to win a pawn even
though only temporarily with Bishop
captures on e6 Queen captures on e6 and
now Knight to d4 now having a triple
attack against the c6 pawn a couple
Blanca doesn't have time to add yet
another defender to the point as his
queen is under attack so he has to move
we have Queen to e5 Knight captures on
c6 Queen captures on c3 rook captures on
c3 and now rook to d2 a very active move
by comparing Kahoot is for the moment
down upon but he's ready to grab that B
to pawn and here
Marshall has an option he can either go
for an active move or he can try to
defend his extra pawn and since he
already grabbed upon from capablanca he
wants to defend it here he played rook
to be one where there was a possibility
to go rook the c1 just to give up the b2
pawn for activity and after captures now
go Knight to e5 you want to go
see seven you want to go after this pawn
and it's very very likely that this game
would end in a in a very quick draw
let's say rook d8 f3 now defending this
pawn or either you could go instead of
defending Roxy 7 and allow this rook to
D to move which would really allow black
to go for a quick draw now but you could
also go for f3 captures on a 2 now comes
rook to c7 just going after that pawn
but now h5 a very nice move that again
offers it offers the draw we're after a
capture so you can go just through d2 d2
and now you will not be able to to get
out of check check King h7 captures here
and mouth after will capture son g2 King
h1 captures here you will constantly be
able to keep checking the the White King
even though you're down piece doesn't
really matter so this is one of the
possibilities that Marshall had but
maybe he just wasn't interested in a
draw against kappa blanka with the white
pieces especially after that game 2 loss
to Capablanca in round 1 which was just
insane if you haven't seen it it's the
first link in the description below just
a wild game rook the b1 marshal says I
grabbed upon I'm gonna defend it but
here kappa blanka goes rook to e8 now
pressures this pawn and you have to
decide how to defend it if you go f3
then f5 you're not really going to keep
your intact bone structure here so
marshall decides to go for he 5 and now
there's a problem you always kind of
have to keep an eye on this Bishop
captures and just rook capture Sonny on
e5 but for the moment it's not possible
as there are some background quickness
for a cup of vodka so he deals he does
wood both of the marshals idea so with
one with g5 now freeing some space for
the Kings so Blanca gets rid of all the
background weaknesses and also he
doesn't allow f4 which would allow
Marshall to consolidate in the center so
Marshall goes h4 he decides to give up
one pawn to allow him it to play f4 at
some point but also to just mess up
copper 1 cos bone structure Capablanca
says thank you for a pawn this idea is
really bad we have G captures on h4 and
now Marshall has some problems if he
goes for
for maybe s plan King h8 and now you're
not really gonna have a lot of fun
defending this g-tube on and on the
other hand after G captures on h4 if you
play something like knife captures here
just rook captures on e5 and now Ruby g5
is again coming to G to Bishop piling up
on that G to pawn not a lot you can do
here so here marshal realizes that it's
not really possible to play something
like this he decides for to go for rook
to e1 he says okay you just grab a pawn
I'm just gonna consolidate here you know
but capablanca is not interested here a
couple blanca goes rooked ecigs he says
okay i I do a nice rook lifts with an ax
with a double attack against your knight
but also I'm ready to go rook to g6 at
some point to pressure your G to pawn we
have rook eat the c1 now finally
Marshall doubles up on the C file so as
you can see Capablanca is really playing
amazing chess here as the Marshall was
well not forced but first went rogue b1
then on the second move human truck
he won then he went rook c1 not really
achieving anything in the position and
well it's all due to Capablanca a you
know an insane level of play so okay for
the moment you can go rogue g6 do 297
you will just lose that rook so couple
wonka just goes to kink to g7
he prepares rook to g6 with b4 by
marshall and now comes b5 not allowing
b5 by white consolidate with the knight
on c6 with a three by marshall now at
least his sponsor and on the Queen's
either are no longer targets and now we
have looked at g6 with King to f1 you
have to play some move but there really
isn't a good move to play here with King
to f1 as h3 was a threat the G to pawn
would have been pinned there and now
kappa blanka just goes rook to a 2 and
this if you look at it creates a
beautiful su Kwong where any move
marshall makes will just be a terrible
move so you can't move this rogue this
rock has to keep an eye on the a3 pawn
and also on the night the same goes for
this rook you can't really move this
rook both rooks are required to not lose
a piece for white you can't go back with
the King if you go back just h3 if you
go back to the e-file then just
captures here the only move you can make
and it's in fact the best defense for
white is this silly six move which
either offers to get to the rook out of
the G file so you will no longer have
any threats or F captures on e6 which is
a nice clean pawn but then Marshall is
able to play rook to d3 and threaten
rook to d7 check which would win the
bishop capablanca would go Bishop
captures on c6 with rook captures and c6
and now rook to a1 check force the King
out of the defense of the G to pawn king
e2 and not rook captures and g2 and now
it's very hard position to play for for
white cover Blanca of material with a
very dangerous past H pawn marshal well
my mean marshal of course looked at this
move but he didn't like it he knew that
the endgame was lost against Capablanca
so he tried to kink the g1 he allows
Capablanca this age remove with h3 by
capablanca and now g3 of course you
cannot capture and now comes a six and
it's a really disgusting position to be
in for white with east six now by
Marshall but now as the rook is no
longer neither than the G files even
captures with the rope with rook
captures and e6 and now G for preparing
f3 we have looked back to h6 not
allowing rook captures on h3 just f3 now
defending the g4 pawn and now capablanca
just return it so rook to d6 now the
rook is coming to d2 and there is not
all that much Marshall can do with
Knight to e7 hoping for Knight to f5
check winning the rook but capablanca
just goes rogue d2 d2 with Knight to f5
check hoping to trick Capablanca one
last time of course if King goes here
then you can just give up one rope for
checkmate capture send checkmate as the
knight is controlling east 7 and g7
Abbott Capablanca is you know not not an
easy person to trick with King to f6 now
comes nice to h4 capablanca just brings
the King deeper into the position
King g5 attacks the night Marshall has
to go back we have looked the g2 check
King to f1 with h2 preparing for h1
checkmate
Marshall played f4 check just you know
and ice check to end the game kinky
ters on f4 and it was in this position
that Frank James Marshall resigned the
game as well as you can see there's
nothing you can do here so look I mean
but it's just beautiful of course each
one a queen or a rookie just wins the
game there's no defense against this you
can prolong the game by silly moves like
rook f3 check but we're not even gonna
cover those so just a wonderful game by
Capablanca with the black pieces against
Frank Jeff Marshall really just two
beautiful games against Frank James
Marshall in this tournament and it's
really you know all comes down to that
moment you look at this final position
look at couple Blancas beautiful Bishop
on b7 completely slicing the board in
half Columbus two active rooks and
remember that moment where we mentioned
with that Marshall could have gone for
something like Knight Queen to e5 just
increasing the pressure maybe bring the
other work into the game figure out
where to go from there but he decided to
give up his light square bishop which is
basically the only piece able to counter
cover Blancas light square bishop but up
for this well temporary temporary pawn
as we mentioned captures captures and in
the end he wasn't he wasn't even able to
to keep on to this pawn that well he he
so greedily jumped upon as a roof to
lead to just such an active move I mean
going after B to Ruby 1 it seems like
I'm just repeating the game we've
already seen but such such a you know
such a decision will cost you the game
against the player of Koppelman cos
caliber and in the end after this well
now position the this night here and
this beautiful Bishop like like we
already said a slicing the board in half
just just amazing yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and remember if
you want to improve your game you know
study the endgame that's that's the only
way to do it and then after you reach 24
2500 then you can study openings but
yeah at once again I would like to thank
Paul Givens and Krishna or Manik for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos your
thing called for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the Capablanca saga
with this 1918
your tournament then we're heading into
Capablanca smash against Serbian
Grandmaster Bora Kostich and then we of
course go for the World Chess
Championship match capablanca vs. Lasker
that we are preparing for well for such
a long time already so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day